In the next few months, she began to be promoted.
Her career turned.
Why?
This was a dating breakup.
Why is her career taking off?
Because when you find purpose and meaning in what you're doing,...
...in one area of your life,...
...it grows in every area of your life because you are one person.
That company had a woman coming in with the same dresses on,...
...body looked the same, but it wasn't the same employee.
This was a woman now full of leadership for the first time.
When someone has that meaning and that integrity, things start to change.
The research says when you give up self-interested goals,...
...where most of us are most of the time,...
...and you take on contributive goals, you function differently.
The biology changes.
The thought process changes.
Learning accelerates.
You grow more.
The only thing that I'm left to conclude is,...
...you and I are designed to be purpose-seeking mechanisms.
You've been shaped by life, you've had bad experiences and good experiences,...
...and both the bad experiences and the good experiences are there...
...to teach you something about you.
And if you look very carefully at those, you can determine what your purpose is.
Every person in this room can clarify the purpose of their life,...
...become the key to every door.